I'm gonna go back a little bit
when I first met side of Cincy in New
Zealand I was a second and under an Ikea
UK certification system because that was
pretty much all we had there was a
Japanese teacher in the UK who who
awarded
um
ikikai certification but I wasn't but
that he was doing the Honda Starlight
kiddo and I'd met sight of sense to you
before that
and I've chosen here while my kiddo so I
held a second dad in UK certification
but nothing else
the cytosensity in New Zealand saw me
looked at me and he said well
um
I'm Michael Kai
and therefore I'm gonna
award you first down Nike and that way
you can collect it off the certificate
off the English
the Japanese master in England
make a link with them and then it will
keep the system if you like the politics
side
as it should
and so that's why I became an my first
uh Dan ikikai
he also after that over the years
awarded me
second and third down I remember my
third down I was called out of the
shower because since the somebody was
banging on the door since he wanted me
and he wanted me instantly and when he
wants you you even in the shower you
gotta be ready and there so I pouring
the sweat sat there
and um
uh stamp running said Sensei has decided
he's going to award you third down
I was at this stage fourth down UK
certification
and I didn't mind I was filling up the
wall with certificates paying for
British Ones playing for Japanese ones
what does it really matter you know to
me I've got my master but the people in
the UK said no you're far too good
uh
so when I got my fourth down it was from
a different organization in the UK
because I I was asked to
um take part in a demonstration
and it was an annual event for all the
British Aikido organizations
on what they called the British Aikido
board
I done my demonstration of course my
demonstration was such a senses Aikido
not
the Hut where I'd been
practicing and still was practicing
this was I think in 1992 it might be the
91 or 92.
I'd done the demonstration and this
person who become a very good friend
close friend
from that point on
and he said that was amazing your
demonstration
or organization are you with and I said
oh I'm with the
The Institute of vicodo
more than happy there because every time
I'd go on a site of sense of seminar the
teachers Mr Foster who was the head then
he would say uh
show us what Mr site I used quite Mr
Saito rather than Sensi
show us what Mr side has taught you
so Mr Foster would be taking a seminar
somewhere that I would be on every month
to remember I would be on a seminar
somewhere in the world but also in the
UK every month without fail for 23 years
and um the people would come up to me
off was in the changing room and say who
Do You Think You Are
Sergeant usually
who do you think you are demonstrating
we didn't come to pay to see you and I
said uh Mr Foster asked me to do I
didn't ask to do it
so I started getting bad feelings within
my own organization that I'd been in
since a knowledge belt
and on the after this demonstration this
person saying what organization are you
with I told them they said no way he
said no way he said you need to be
forming your own organization
so at that turning point I wrote a sign
of the fancy and um
I said I wanted to
start my own organization
I then linked up with some of the people
in America
and in started in I started the whole
organization with another person another
senior
we started inviting the American
teachers from the Oakland dojo
and um
one was Pat Hendricks who became
one of the main people who we would have
every year
to come and teach us
but we had many
and so hence we started traditional
Aikido or traditional only one like it
up
we added the Euro later on when we had
clubs want to be part of us from Masha
and Greece
so
just before cytosens his death I had a
call from my fifth Dan I was a fifth Dan
I got my FIT down in Iran cytosense he
said on one of the seminars around the
world Tony you've never been to oama if
you want your fifth down you've got to
come to your armor to get it
so we made the arrangements and one in
1994 we organized a seminar in
Birmingham the UK for cytosension to
come
because he was he'd already organized
one in Italy
under Pella corlini
and it was a beautiful area that he
would be teaching in that in those times
aussiemo on the on the sea fund and it
was very nice place to go so I decided I
would go to warmer for three weeks
before this I would come back with
cytosensei to Italy where we would have
another long seminar and then on to the
UK where we would have our final seminar
together this was in as I say 1994.
August through to September
more and more people didn't like me on
each seminar because Saito says he
Favored Me
I didn't ask to be favored I've never
been asked to be favored I actually even
though I might seem on the mat and when
I'm talking about Aikido I may seem
really positive person you know and
really full of energy and perhaps a
leader
but I didn't choose to be a teacher when
I was a first queue I didn't choose to
be asked to be psyched with sight and
Scentsy wherever he go it went that was
his decision
but the people who used to invite him
weren't in the car they weren't next to
him they didn't you know
stand in the corridor in the middle of
the night if since he wanted to go at
the toilet because I could you know used
to sleep he would he sleeps with a pin
and dropped
anyhow for some reason the electricity's
gone out and we'll continue this
story soon thank you for listening